[Musik]
einen schönen guten morgen mal daran
herrlich bewacht und ja ich merke dass
ich nicht mehr schlafen
die welt hört ihr euch nochmal den
blockierer weg in etwa genau vor einem
jahr hochgeladen habe
ob da kann man jetzt nicht so genau der
andere können ruhig da war aber ich war
in amsterdam beim ersten date werden sie
band und das ist ein festival bis das an
die welt dass man eine woche samstag in
jedem club mitglieder ba sind geile die
these die hausmusik auf und wollte
wieder will er jetzt jetzt kommt erstmal
vorbei das filmblut kapitza das ist
gerade einfach der vierte oder fünfte
tag in folge an dem ich pizza essen
schmeckt trotzdem danke fürs münchner
ist nachdem es die pizza gegessen haben
dusche ich mich jetzt erstmal ab weil
ich meine ich stehe heute hart wie
scheiße ich habe jetzt meine sachen
gepackt finden wir gar noch ein bisschen
geholfen
dann endlich gar nicht geholfen auf
jeden fall eine spülmaschine
angestellten müll mitgenommen da vorne
stehen und zusammen haben ist ada monday
wir fahren jetzt erst mal nach
düsseldorf locken doch gestern musste
made in düsseldorf halle kommen direkt
der innenstadt freut uns dort in
düsseldorf angekommen ich habe mal
wieder lust gepackt wir befinden uns in
einer rasch setzte auf den gegner
fordern ich wohne gerne packen dreimal
er kann in einer raststätte in holland
war nicht zu treffen aber wir fahren
jetzt nach amsterdam
bruno ist übrigens am start hier der
kleine weg
nach einer langen und schweren fahrzeuge
jetzt gerade in amsterdam angekommen
alle zusammen
dieser verkehr kurzen können aber
amsterdam ist einfach so schön freunde
egal wohin man guckt deswegen das ist
sondern dass das gleich das ein bisschen
aus dem auto fahren
lukas ist da ich gerade gemacht und ich
habe eine flasche auf genannten in
anderen platzierung wird ist einfach der
decke des tradings auge geflogen
es ist rot ich kann es mir das gucken
also ohne spaß ich halte jetzt mal sagen
es ist mit augen geflogen ich habe nur
weiß gesehen ich bin direkt aus ging's
gerannt direkt aus den stars hat
normalen spiegel gekoppelt haben nur
weiß gesehen
junge wie sieht das denn aus halte ich
dachte mir nicht weil die man eigentlich
dann also ungelogen ich habe so was noch
nie gehabt jetzt im auge es gibt gerade
so aus also es hängt hier quasi so ein
bisschen runter also es auf jeden fall
noch mehr ins auge gehen können
auf jeden fall wollte sich kramer gerade
neues aus dem kühlschrank holen jetzt
guck ich das einmal war das alles war
auf man denkt so da ist auf jeden fall
genug als ja gerne alle mega spaß und
lukas
[Musik]
schönborn ich will bleiben wie geht es
im klub das heißt die nächsten aufnahmen
stellen mit mandy seien entwurzelt mir
freunde hier gehen grafik zum club damen
und herren
davon haben wir alex carola und filter
und jetzt übrigens auch die block noch
beschissen hat sich tatsächlich jene
schlafen
ich finde es auf jeden fall das duschen
vermutlich durch gucken dich nicht
geradestehen wenn ich vater ist
amsterdam des mega fucking fresh alter
dankeschön an unsere bude ist echt der
blick nach draußen ok sogar ist auch
nicht klug als ich glaube ich gerade
aufs maul gelegt also aufs maul gelegt
das schönste wetter ist luca einfach
nicht fertig da der keine einzige
eine lassen
[Musik]
ungelogen man tritt auf mehr bier ist es
die fucking schönste stadt der welt
komme jetzt ferne sogar leute mit ihrem
schmuck her warum haben wir kein boot
freunde von la corse davon ist dann
heilen
wir wollen einfach nur was essen würde
der kann von einem zuschauer und guckt
der san luca ist litt amsterdam
ihr habt keine vernünftige scheren hat
im café klatsch gefordert dass er wird
weiter zeit ich noch nicht nicht sogar
wir sind weggegangen vom restaurant war
carola jetzt ihre und ihre freunde
treffen vorbild nicht kann mich immer
nur wiederholen von diese stadt ist
nicht hässlich diese stadt kann ich
herzlich sein das ist dass es viel zu
schön hier einfach oder film ja jetzt
wieder scheiße ich alter kommen ist ja
irgendwie nerven
letztes jahr war ich auch dabei sind wir
jetzt ja nicht das weltuntergangs
stimmung geraten
auf dem felde todes am regnen ungelogen
zehn sekunden später und es sieht
einfach wieder so aus dass in dieser
stadt los
[Applaus]
herr auges gestern kaputtgegangen sieht
man dass wir auch wieder nach
1 ausgegangen dass man august ist mein
auge ist gestern haben sie meine damen
und herren und ja ich weiß jetzt dabei
ist eigentlich keine wirkliche
pc-arbeitsplätzen carola hat da so ein
bisschen von kira pizza vegetarier
vielleicht
das
ja
norwich und ringen vor und und
das sind dann auf dem konzert und
[Musik]
marketing genutzt werden dabei
guten morgen meine damen und herren wir
sind mittlerweile auch mal macht es ist
gerade gegen 10 30 oder sogar bis jetzt
gleich aus dieser wundervollen wohnung
hier auschecken freunde alter schrift
keinen schöneren place und es dann
packen erdgeschoss bruder kalte
fließendes tolles und dann kommt direkt
aus und floss meine damen und herren die
sachen sind fertig zusammengepackt die
sagt es allerdings das ist mein koffer
viel zu leicht so geht
ich glaube ich habe noch immer sehen die
wohnung vergessen wo carlo chicken
sandwich und hier vorne schön sexy
gesetzlichkeit in person
wir haben auf gehst in einem café das
echten total überteuert war einfach
gerade jetzt gerade auf den huber und
dann werden wir leider diese
wunderschöne stadt verlassen
meine freunde lieben mich auch halo
bruder
mit
dank junge was ist das hier für eine
back untergangsstimmung alter hauptsache
billig deutschland direkt sowie der
abend zu hause angekommen
meine damen und herren und jetzt wir
haben nichts zu essen dann doch wir
haben pizzen deine spiel keine spitze
übrig gelassen wenn ihr seht wir haben
gerade einfach bürger bestellt und die
würden gerade geliefert und na ja
normalerweise sich dadurch zeigt sich
mal eben es sich gebunden ist ein bruder
des hd salaten der lachs der offenburger
war und naja das obere brot fehlt
tatsächlich ist nicht drin ruft jetzt
gerade bei dem laden an und bat oder
edel stars jetzt verstanden flieger mit
den ganzen platz ins schleudern hast du
bock alter ich gebe euch schön bat geil
freut mich
diesmal
von bei chronisch aus es ist unnormal
kalt draußen geschaut jetzt gemacht wenn
das irgend mittlerweile richtig schön
früher wollte ich mich in diese wirklich
hinter diesen eisbahn aber jetzt mal den
ganzen richtern und so sind die
arbeitsrechten 1 aus
[Musik]
die steht der libido irgendwie regieren
sport ihren gehe ich weiß nicht mehr wie
er damit vermied ausgesprochen wird das
ich nicht kann auf jeden fall meine
damen und herren würde ich den blogger
dieser stelle ist auch beenden der blog
ist noch nicht bei 100 aber die drei
tage von freitag samstag und jetzt
gerade sind wir am sonntagabend
angekommen ich habe halt keine lust oder
zusammen dann die ganze zeit immer eine
kamera mit zu nehmen und so weiter und
so fort deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ich
schneide das lieber so zusammen dass die
drei tagen in einem blog dann hab ich
gesagt gefallen hat meine damen und
herren und die mehr braucht haben wollt
dann hat man sonst nicht sagen
[Musik]